we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p you know one of the
blessings and simultaneously curses that
we've seen over the last four months
is that the audience has exploded in
size
that's a really great thing from the
standpoint of reaching more people
but it has also brought in all sorts of
new haters trolls
trumpists and uh tools of the right wing
uh
movement that are regularly trolling me
and sometimes the critiques are just
really lame here's a guy
who could come up with nothing more
creative to say
then my mouth is physically large he
said my mouth is big
listen to this hello i have a very quick
uh
question for you uh pac-man why is your
mouth so wide
like i'm not here to judge i'm not gonna
say like i'm the perfect looking guy but
you know
it's a very interesting question why why
your mouth is at least you know
200 yards long you can
convert that into metric if you want to
i won't
uh i'd really appreciate if you got my
questions as possible and uh thank you a
lot
yeah i mean i think the answer if to
answer seriously i think it's just
genetics right i mean i
i i assume i am the genetics of uh
of my parents but this is the type of
stuff that
is i mean it's daily stuff like this uh
there's another guy obsessed with the
fact that
i use my hands when i talk that's the
big critique of the show
it doesn't matter what i say it doesn't
matter what what anybody
i'm using my hands when i talk so i'm
hoping that a lot of these folks
as they i think they may be on a come
down
in a sense as they realize that joe
biden's going to be president and so
they still want to keep calling in and
attacking and engaging but there's no
factual basis on which to engage with me
because biden won and they're furious
and
and all of that so instead they're
focusing on stuff like this it's sad to
see
but unfortunately it's very very common
and uh we to some degree i believe we'll
have to continue dealing with it we have
a
fantastic bonus show for you today
in california there is growing anger
about stay-at-home orders and we are
starting to hear from
sheriffs who say they will not be
enforcing the stay-at-home orders and
i have a lot to talk about regarding
this we also now are seeing
lab-grown meat go on sale for the first
time we've been covering lab-grown meat
for a decade
from when it was hundred thousand
dollars for an ounce
and we said the price will come down
this will be a thing in our lifetimes
no kill lab-grown meat is now going on
sale for the first time we will talk
about it
and also very interesting revelations
about my accent i have friends from the
south
who say i have a new york accent
obviously i don't they just i think a
lot of us northerners sound
the same to them um i have people who
write and say oh david you're based in
boston i can hear your boston accent
i've never believed i had a boston
accent i didn't grow up in boston
and we finally have taken a dialect test
and the revelations are explosive i hope
that they don't end the show because
they are controversial but we will
discuss all of that and more
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com